the Greenland ice sheet is the second
largest body of ice in the world after
Antarctica rising temperatures driven by
climate change mean it's melting now
scientists have managed to quantify how
much and how fast providing the most
complete picture available to date and
it's a worrying one since 1992 Greenland
has lost three point eight trillion tons
of ice enough to raise global sea levels
by ten point six millimeters and the
rate of ice loss is speeding up to from
33 billion tonnes per year in the 1990s
to 254 billion tons per year at the
moment that's a seven fold increased
within the last three decades it's
estimated the sea level rise will bring
a million people in the UK into annual
floods by the end of the century but the
estimates for sea level rise are on the
lower side there are under estimates we
can see that from the results that we've
shown today Greenland is losing ice
faster than expected we expect that to
lead to another forty or fifty thousand
people experience including all over the
world the effects of rising seas are
already being felt coastal communities
even in the UK becoming more vulnerable
to storm surges and extreme weather
events the devastation in the Bahamas
after hurricane durian another example
of what can happen to low-lying island
nations the only way to truly limit
further sea level rises is to limit
global warming by drastically reducing
the amount of greenhouse gases we emit
but scientists warn that no matter what
we do the slow process of melting ice
will continue for decades to come a
constant and evolving threat on a planet
increasingly strained by the effects of
climate change
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News